so if I go straight on some work me out
and to another's do you feel happy and
here's a funny little point because you
look at this working and you look at
your answer the number that you get a
photo and then you look back at the
question you're like oh that's fun you
know it doesn't even down to what I need
right like I could round that to or not
anything that will be fine okay yeah
firstly okay but it's approximately what
is approximately meaning in this case
I'm quite happy to say that is
approximately to read one line fifty
because they haven't said to how many
decimal places or anything like that I'm
totally okay with that
just as a little side note this figure
here as you see in the past you got to
make sure even if distance a two three
one nine or a four a five
I cannot round down in this sense even
though a for shoot round down to 48 why
can't I round down if I round it down
even by point four of a cent right wait
for it same kind of that is when you do
it three hundred times and over the
course of 25 years you will not pay off
the entire theme if you just go a little
short a little bit sure every single
time
so as in cases where we've been my fault
at what point do I get to this enough or
what point does a population grow to
this amount you've got to make sure you
get that up so that's not - that's the
end
5:3 I'm not the what would you say I'm
not gonna hold your hand through it I
want you to read me and let's just
unpack a strategy for it he says after
how many months will be narrowing
become less than a hundred and eighty
thousand dollars after how many months
will the amount owing be less than 180
quick question hundred eight thousand
Olson ran over here so he wants to
okay so then they try to find out at
what point we live in halfway
paying off the actual death okay how am
I going to do this what equations am I
gonna fall in I'm gonna get into this
point over here huh - we met straight to
300 what information hold on how do I
know to make it 300 where did that
number come from
it's a number of something but what's
something in the question that's that's
how long it takes you to be paid right
or how long it takes ariram a so that's
where I got that number for now I do not
know that number for this class compadre
so it's n okay but I do know what it
should be it should be 180,000 so I'm
just going to leave that there just like
this first line Fiamma it's not the
answer but it sets the trajectory for
you how you define that also have a look
at what I've written over there I've
said the amount owing will be exactly
underneath puzzle when and then I form
this equation sorry video so I thought
that the fact that if you had a look at
the question the most technically
correct way to actually monitor these
with inequality because I want to be
even less than right but I'm gonna do
with it as an equation because they
don't have to worry about
let's head right hand side and logs and
what have you and they don't find that
point in jeopardy Oscar point so have a
look at what I've written this is just
my expression of a of M of a left hand
side we've one difference which is that
the expression camper a of M had the
limit and Venus right over that cuz it
was but as of the end of Part two
I know what the month your hand is so
I'm I put it in place okay you might be
others are slight sort of rounding
issues going on here but they told you
in the question they said this is
that is so you can always use that I
know math even if you couldn't do part
two you can do part rate by using okay
so I hope this into place I can simplify
this a bit Kansai because that
multiplied by 200 is just a number I
wonder so we can tell me what it is but
if you use which value it is the English
throughout the building
why did you use the rounded value I
don't need that much value that we found
out so is it interesting for you this
question is his scaffold at NBC's cap
operations all the time when is part 1
in this pattern and then the real
question we actually really want to ask
is right here in the end now if in part
one and two earlier parts if you venue
some kind of rounded up series thinking
you know this is the most precise level
it's what we went now we had more detail
so this will give you and this this
comes more into plan say for example
when you do remember you did not reach a
sine or cosine rule and you do like a
bearings question and then you'd be like
Paul on my money
so base in that direction is like you
get the exact angle to get there and
then you have like a decimal place so to
the nearest minute or something like
that but Finley if you actually bound
and you go do that
you know in five of your poem is that
distance you can actually end up in a
little bit all right so you'll always
better off using more precision how I
love when they give you a number
they actually have ready in them our
decision to solutions based on whether
you use the exact line or the provided
Norma
provide you in the month they have to
let you say I'm gonna use that them all
so I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna use
this bequeath it does simplify my
working a teeny bit and because I have
sort of the thumbs up from them to use
the rounded figure I'm gonna go do this
however just for the provider that if
you wanted like actual accuracy you were
burning around at the very very final
step right every time you introduce
around even more work when you do with
it the more your arrow just kind of gets
bigger bigger bigger does that make
sense
okay so special case in which I can use
this song and surround the big up
because they told you because I'd like
to take in going home nine nine eight
just let me do okay they don't got the
rest of my brackets and then this is the
figure I'm looking for okay now what
this will be for these guys it's all we
fit in how long they might be in it and
the end is nestled up here in the power
okay so I'm gonna have to get all of my
ends to get up in one spot since it's
something the power I'm going to have to
use as well on the way so I'm going to
take this guy and I'm going to expand
out why what must I say it's because of
these kind of light like there's two
separate ones I need to get them in one
spot that's just changing the subject
101 right so Trinity mm to take away
that many how many more points here is
verified to the ends will that leave you
take away is it gonna be
[Music]
I'm a mathematician okay that's alright
1:33 know that right yep 900 months of
this yes okay yes correctly I'm only a
couple of thoughts so I'm not a hundred
percent company there you have no paper
or not all right
I'm extending this as well so there's a
double negative plus four six three 900
and is this okay clearly on my way I've
got I mean you're single and left but I
got all of this mystery so I can
subtract this from - and you can see
here this is not that hard to deal with
right up up you might practice custody
changes what I just need to divide
through both sides would you give me one
point you're in there - the end I'm
gonna get a fraction here right I'd like
to keep this exactly the same reason the
notes will be none before
well in the fracture mode come on yeah
exactly
she bites you know yes I'm putting my
life in your name is Dyson Frost Abel's
life already now they get it right so
I'm going to take longer suppose I'll
rewrite this thing this is log base the
base stays the same this is this number
over here you can use
space to work out what this is and then
I think I'm going to get our decimal
places right so as we've mentioned in
the past you get to a number and then
your task is to interpret this so what
does it mean I'm looking for number of
months right now I'll go like a
fractional number of months so I want to
get power step thing cuz I look back the
question when do I cause I'm in 8,000 so
I'm gonna say after 202 months and
that's actually my solution now it's
always important when you can to number
one no employment that means in number
two to assess check that's so I'm gonna
get some numbers your whole life in a
second but before I do think about what
this means
how long is the black of the Lord it's
300 months right so with like two-thirds
the way in will be four years after the
actual chronological halfway point two
thirds away and when we finally pay off
the line
two thirds the way in and you pay off
the loan so my question to you is why is
this so slow why is it so long after
half way that we may actually make it
past half way now to help you sort of
get your head around this question
because some people got a figure that
was quite different to this and you said
shaggy this I'm not running Vicky
to tell you this copyright somebody's
gonna drastically wrong it's gonna be
more than that
Paul can you tell me how because you
were getting one right
and Michael 358
very okay put your pens down throw it
and let me make you depressed for a
moment okay
we started at three hundred and sixty
thousand dollars right have a look at
the tiny tiny dent we made in that three
hundred sixty thousand dollars
after a month right how much was the
repayment again it was this right so
you'd be like oh cool
two thousand dollars of it right you
haven't even got $1,000 offer you've
just barely knocked off half of that
five hundred twenty thousand is how did
you actually reduce the principal and
it's a lot different when you go to the
next one right so what's going on
remember do you remember a nation to Z
so this kind of represents the original
loan and just keeps growing and growing
like forever
but then these guys over here represent
all your repayments all added up right
and they kind of into tug of war this
guy is huge
these guys are tiny but eventually they
just outnumber this three hundred right
so you eventually they have love in this
amount okay but that doesn't stop the
principal from fighting that's why this
number goes down so very slowly at the
beginning at the start of your life you
repay up on anything in fact this is bad
someone's a really interesting it's in
the region today that's why we gotta
pass halfway and playoff the halfway
actually does that make sense